good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy friday
friday gotta get down on friday
it is friday and i am so excited to be
joined by podcaster influencer um beauty
tnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnn
sister lauren elizabeth hey lauren hey
girly girl how are you doing today how
you doing um how you darn i'm good i um
you know our mutual producer texted me
1700 times reminding me um what time
zone i'm on so i am here and
that's only that's no slight against you
it's only because we've had so many
guest co-hosts and the remote ones like
we always [ __ ] up the time zones you
just assume when you get an email like
it's gonna be in your time zone yeah i
mean like i understand that but at the
same time like i actually never know
time zones and she chose that as well so
it's like a mutual understanding but i'm
just like happy to be here i obviously
saw you literally seven days ago so it's
just kind of like weird that we're now
recording together it's a lot for sure
are you getting sick of me
no i'm not i honestly just like it's
weird recording on um the podcast with
you and not just watching you uh wash
your hair in the bathtub you know yeah
that's what we do on facetime yeah um
it's been a minute since you've been on
the toast i don't think you've been on
since la week before the pandemic well i
think there was one
i was thinking about it but i was still
living in west hollywood so it was
before i bought my house before i moved
to chicago and i think it was when it
was my first merch drop with you guys
like for the podcast
and
it was you me and jackie and i remember
just being like so nervous i feel like i
have imposter syndrome with the toast
for some reason because i'm just like i
don't know it's because it's like this
cult following and they're so passionate
and like i know that there's crossover
but for some reason i realized this
morning while i was getting ready i was
like i have imposter syndrome i was like
why don't i just like be myself like be
yourself you're the best
we're just gonna you know we're just
gonna
we're gonna try to make this the best
toast that i've ever been on it's gonna
be the best toast i want to catch up
with you before we dive in because like
i said it's been a minute since you have
been on the toast you moved back to
chicago i sure did you're chicago gal a
midwestern girly how is that going for
you i mean i love it if there's any
midwest girlies out there it is just
like you get it like i my i was on
therapy on tuesday like after i saw you
in chicago and everything and i was just
like i'm having
so much fun this is just the best city
i'm so happy and i was like i just don't
want to have to go back to boring la and
she's like stop saying la's boring it's
not boring and
i'm sorry but like it is and i asked my
brother i said where would you rather go
out la or chicago he was like obviously
chicago it's just chicago is the best i
mean you met the chicago toasters like
they turn up no and every time i go to
chicago i really like could imagine
myself living there it's such a great
city
and it's so much better than new york in
so many ways and i really enjoy it so i
totally get why you're having this like
renaissance with chicago well it's
because we had this little thing called
the chicago fire and it's like the city
burnt down and so when we rebuilt it we
rebuilt it with alleyways and that's
where we put our trash so what you need
to do is you need to burn new york down
to the ground and rebuild it with
alleyways yeah and you guys also have
those underground like highways right
streets
i mean
kind of like we have like some that go
down we don't have any of that but i
just feel like that really helps with
traffic oh
oh
yeah i mean
i'm sorry like you know that i love you
and i love the sisters but i do like
chicago better than new york i'm sorry
you know what i i'm not gonna argue with
you there i think chicago is really
really great and i'm so happy that
you're having this like late in light
well not late in life but i mean it is
pretty late in life like how long were
you in l.a for a decade yeah it's a lot
it's a lot and like i said on my youtube
channel i'm being very open and honest
about the fact that i have no idea what
i'm doing with my life because i feel
like a lot of times i pretend and i'm
just kind of over pretending and so you
know this as well i kind of like have to
go back to la like after the summer and
i'm still just like i don't know how to
feel about it i think at first i was
really excited because of the weather
and now i'm just like i don't think i
can do it so
pull
my whole
decide my life i was gonna ask you like
what your plan is but i know that it's
like a triggering topic for you because
you most likely will end up back in l.a
my plan is that i have no plan i'm going
to go back to la but if i'm miserable
like i think that what people don't
realize is like you're allowed to change
your mind and you're allowed to not know
like that's like straight up it's i feel
like and then when you announce
something on the internet everyone like
expects that it's like etched in stone
and so
now i'm just like listen i don't know
i'm gonna change my mind i don't care
one second i hate ellie the next second
i love it like right now i hate it and i
don't want to go back so that might
change in a few months we don't know i i
agree with you normalize changing your
mind like it happens with all of us
we're all human beings like if we're
going to unburden ourselves on the
internet 24 7 you think we're not going
to change our minds 100 but i do i do
agree with you like that's something
that i i don't think a lot of people
speak about when you share your life
online there is this understanding that
like when you make a decision and you
announce it like it that's it like it's
yeah you're good and we're not even
giving like the whole backstory of the
decision you know what i mean and so
it's like i'm like yeah i shared the
decision with you but i also like didn't
tell you like x y and z so now i've
changed my mind and i have to kind of
fill you in you have to be understanding
just a lot but i'm just in this like i
think the key to happiness is just like
not caring and that's kind of what i'm
doing like instead of getting stressed
out i'm like i don't care like maybe
i'll be miserable in a few months yeah
we'll figure it out i mean i've known
you for a long time and i definitely
think you're in like a very unique
season of your life now
it's weird yeah we're like you're just
kind of carefree
similar to margot yeah but a little bit
more like hot mess express version she's
like
like she just got promoted like she's
like in her season of like peeking and
i'm just peeking in a different way of
like i don't care i'm kind of a mess and
i'll get my life together eventually
whereas like margo's very much like
i mean someone's about to snatch her up
snatch up the snitch but there's no
right way to to do it you know
i guess i guess you're right well i love
you and i'm so happy you're here and i
can't wait to dive into the past five
years
and i just watched your most recent i
know i'm so excited
oh you did yeah oh yeah because you were
like in it for a second
waiting for the footage of me and there
was none
yeah
okay so i forget to film horizontal a
lot of times um so i only had vertical
i lost my voice from your show um
i only have vertical i only have
vertical footage of you but you're all
over my tick tock yes oh by the way
absolute feral rat can we talk about
your tick tock because it is so crazy
how like every single one of your videos
goes viral
okay
remember when it started though remember
you facetimed me like two months ago and
you're like [ __ ] you're going viral on
tick tock and i was like yeah i know
what's going on and now every time i
post like my tick tock does really well
and i don't know the secret sauce it's
so crazy i think what you have i think
what i've learned is two things one
i used to be so hard on myself about
like having my brand make sense on each
platform and similarly to i don't care
i'm like tick tock is one thing my
podcast is another thing yeah my
instagram is another thing because like
what human being doesn't have multiple
sides to their personality no you know
so true if you go to tick-tock i'm gonna
be a feral club rat yeah no i do think
for a while like you were very
militaristic about like what content
goes on what platform yeah and then when
you kind of let yourself just go like
your tick tock is so good and i was
looking at it the other day because you
posted a really cute tick tock that like
really went viral of us in chicago yeah
i was like damn every single one of this
bitch's videos has like hundreds and
thousands of views
i mean if only those numbers would
transfer over you know what i mean girl
i'm on the struggle bus with you as well
when it comes to tick tock but i just
wanted to say i'm very proud and jealous
of you thank you all you have to do is
uh use the viral songs that's literally
all you have to do
it's really not that simple though it is
i swear to god that's all i do no like
somebody who works at tick tock put you
in like a special basket of people yeah
yeah and then they're sure then they put
me in a basket of degenerate rats who
cannot get any engagement whatsoever
shut the [ __ ] up no i'm telling you it's
true no your tick tock does well
i i watch it sometimes i go to yours to
see like what you're lip-syncing over to
um
see if there's something that i should
do oh i swear to god i have like three
in my drafts just from like you the
mental hospital one where it was like i
would check myself in the hospital today
but i have things to do
but see i i also do the click bait so
like what i did the caption was when i
have to talk about my breakup online
instead of going to therapy and then
everyone was like oh my god
well let's talk about that you're a
single girly now i know isn't it amazing
how are you doing like single wise you
think you can get your heart broken once
let me tell you it can happen twice
and in a 12-month period um
yeah so
this one's a lot different because it
was a little bit more amicable it wasn't
as long of a relationship it was a
little more situational um i didn't go
into like a deep dark hole where i lost
a lot of weight this time which was like
a little upsetting i was like why do i
still have my appetite right yeah no i'm
obviously just kidding um but yeah it's
good i mean it was like a sad few months
but like being in chicago this time and
just being able to like lean on you guys
in new york my friends in chicago my
family here and just like literally say
yolo and i said on my vlog whenever you
say yolo it means you're about to make a
bad decision 100 and
that's where we're at so i'm honestly
fine which is shocking information yeah
but i'm happy for you and you know what
like it is what it is
know that i am
it's fine like everything happens for a
reason so you might not know at this
moment like why that happened but in
like a year you will know exactly why do
you wanna know what you said to me after
the breakup do you remember no i was
dying we were on facetime and you go
in my new york times best-selling book i
don't know if you've read it um i said
and you just started quoting things from
your book and i feel like as a bestie um
that was some you know it was it was
good for me on facetime and then you
started yelling at me on the phone i'm
never not promoting my brand no like
literally me crying on facetime you
promoting your book and then i was like
i honestly am just like afraid that i'm
gonna end up alone and you're like you
know what i'm not living in this [ __ ]
alternate universe you needed to hear
that you needed to hear that i feel like
i'm going to end up alone lauren you're
26
you're 27 and three quarters [ __ ] me
too you're stunning her birthday starts
two days apart
but what i was saying was like
it's totally okay to be sad about a
breakup but like it's not okay to then
slip into delusional thought like the
idea of you ending up alone like you are
successful you are funny you are smart
you are kind you are stunning beautiful
stunning and smart like there's just no
possibility in the world that you were
going to not be able to find someone so
like that is where i drew the line with
my sympathy that's where you need to
tough
yeah you're like voice first of all for
podcast listeners i'm shaking my head i
don't take compliments i don't listen to
them they just go right over and then
secondly i like your tone switched you
just started yelling at me and then 20
seconds later you hung up the phone well
you needed to hear it i'm sorry like
that's i'm not a friend i i just spent
the rest of the day laughing like it was
honestly amazing but good good good yeah
i don't know what else i was going to
say something else i took my adderall
before this so i'm just
well i was going to ask you because i
was having this conversation with joey
kamas yesterday so if you're a regular
adderall user you take it before i'm
like not really clear on how adderall
works so
you take it before
you work or after
why would i take it after
i don't know so i can focus on watching
tv oh well
like yeah sometimes um
yeah
so uh yeah so i take it before i'm on
like a really low dose when you had
craig conover or no you didn't we're not
talking about yeah paige or whatever and
they were like talking about like taking
adderall and stuff and i was like okay
like let's not shame me like this early
in the morning but yeah i take like a
really low dose for work but then like
sometimes like there's just you know
sometimes push comes to shove and you
just like need it before going to girl
with no job at the chicago theater right
by the way i wasn't shaming at all we
were talking about reality stars who
like no i really have a prescription
yeah like i'm saying like craig and
paige it's like i'm happy for you i'm
also
so cute i literally like it's it's a lot
for me to handle if she moves to
charleston i might move to charleston
because my whole family's moving to
charleston i know you know this i do so
paige if you're listening if you could
find me someone to date in charleston if
you want a friend i'm not opposed to
that idea at all yes i could see you in
charleston i'm actually not a big thirst
monster i really just want like a normal
person that like doesn't have social
media that just wants to impregnate me
like that's honestly all i want you know
what that is so true you are really not
like a thirst monster which is really
shocking since we're such good friends
well i think it's like we're so similar
but then there's some stuff where like i
just let you take the lead and like yeah
is someone who puts themselves online
for a living i hate attention i hate
when people look at me i hate taking
pictures like that's why i [ __ ]
started a podcast is so that i wouldn't
have to like put my
like i would just be able to whatever
and then all of a sudden you're like you
should start taking videos of your
podcast i'm like claudia this is not
what i signed up for girl i'm a business
woman like i know i mean the
entrepreneurial spirit at tnn is just
it's hard we go hard but yeah like i
really like i'm a big hinge girly like i
love going on hinge i love meeting the
midwest boys and i love when they're
like oh like what do you do and i'm like
oh i work in like social media what do
you do they're like oh i went to notre
dame and i'm like that's so hot like
that is so hot a businessman bo for
lauren elizabeth yeah that's all like if
i could literally quit doing what i'm
doing and like maybe just do my podcast
and like tick-tock i would but like i i
don't have a daddy to pay my rent you'll
be there soon thank you so much um so we
should probably dive in yeah i know i
know i'm like looking at the clock i'm
like we have a lot of ground to cover
but i appreciate you sharing opening up
about heartbreak love love lost and i
love you and you're going to join me for
the fast five stories yes that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast
today's episode is brought to you by
away away creates thoughtful products
designed to change how you see the world
they started with the perfect suitcase
crafted with features that make travel
more seamless and now
when even the familiar looks different
you can count on a waze range of
essentials to solve real travel problems
whenever you take that next trip all of
their suitcases at a way are built to
last with durable exteriors that can
withstand even the roughest of baggage
handlers i've been using my away
suitcase since the day i got it it's
something that's gotten me around on
tour it is the greatest product on the
planet the all the wheels are 360 degree
spinner wheels so it's guaranteed to
have the smoothest roll even through the
most hectic of airports and they have a
tsa approved combination lock that keeps
all your belongings safe they're also
designed to expand with their new
expandables collection so you have the
ability and the flexibility to pack even
more into your trip so you can start
your 100 day trial and shop the entire
away lineup of travel essentials
including their best selling suitcases
at awaytravel.com toast that's away
dot com slash toast so the 100 day trial
makes you uh gives you the ability to
take the product on the road live with
it travel with it get lost with it for
100 days and if you decide it's not for
you you can return any non-personalized
item for a full refund during that
period they also offer free shipping and
returns um within the contingency u.s
europe canada and australia again that's
awaytravel.com
toast thank you away for sponsoring
today's episode as well as our next
sponsor bolin branch speaking of
yesterday's episode where we were
talking at length about bowling branch i
heard did you watch i was so funny so
good right you guys sold me on the
sheets too oh by the way they're
literally the best sheets they use 100
organic cotton threads on
for superior softness and a better
night's sleep their sheets aren't just
buttery breathable and impossibly soft
to start they also get softer with each
wash so behind me if you've seen my bed
i have bowling branch sheets i have the
waffle throw um the signature hem sheets
that's what i have they use the highest
quality threads on earth for superior
softness they're made with threads that
are so luxurious they're beloved by
three us presidents and they feel
buttery soft to the touch and are super
breathable so they're perfect for every
season they also have over ten thousand
stellar reviews so that just like helps
um they come in a ton of different
colors and sizes from twin bed up to
california king obviously i have the
king
and i have the white you'll immediately
feel the difference of their iconic
signature sheets 100 free from toxins
which means no pesticides formaldehyde
or other harsh chemicals and their
sheets fit the deepest of mattress and
are labeled with top and bottom tags so
making your bed is easier than ever get
20 off site-wide april 11th to april
17th only on bowlingbranch.com that's
bowlin branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d branch com for 20 offside
site-wide april 11th through the 17th
um okay lauren for our first story like
it's news i refuse to believe that is
true but like it was widely reported
yesterday i know what you're gonna say
pregnant rihanna and asap rocky have
been hit with breakup and cheating
rumors so rumors are swirling that
rihanna and asap rocky who we all know
are expecting their first child any day
now have broken up over cheating
allegations but page six is also told
that the couple is still going strong
they're fine a source says it's not true
meanwhile an eyewitness who saw rihanna
and rocky on a date at um craig's in
west hollywood last week told us she
looked fine and when they walked out
they were fine it felt normal between
them page six also obtained footage of
the pair holding hands as they exited
the restaurant but the rumors started on
thursday when a writer louis pasano
who interview magazine once called
instagram's messiest fashion influencer
claimed on twitter that rihanna and asap
rocky had parted ways so he wrote
rihanna and asap rocky have split
rihanna broke up with him after she
caught him cheating with shoe designer
amina muatti oh my god i love her have
you seen what she looks like gorgeous
she's like literally the most stunning
person on the planet so this like
instagram thirst monster also wrote asap
and amina is not new though and she was
seeing him years ago and also
collaborated with him on a collection of
shoes
so i mean i hate to report news like
that one person on social media like
created um
but it picked up fast like within
within 30 minutes i saw it on e so i did
my investigative journalism obviously
and i went to her tagged photos and i
went to her instagram
and amina is that okay
big fan of her she's so stunning her
shoes are incredible she works she
literally works for fenty and so
there was this yeah like she's one of
their shoe designers like she is
employed by rihanna and so she like
literally designs fenty shoes she
designs her own shoes and then i go to
her instagram her recent post is
literally of rihanna and
it's on her story literally rihanna just
tagged asap rocky as her baby bump on
the vote cover and then i go to amina's
tagged photos and someone like put this
like little like facts we know and it
said that amina got fired from fenty and
i don't think that's true right because
she was just posting rihanna
12 hours ago as of last night wait
that's such an interesting piece first
of all i'm learning so much from this
story first of all i didn't know that
the woman he was rumored to have hooked
up with was amina mawadi which just
takes his story to like such fashion
a-list moment how could he be that dumb
though like i know her right like you
and i didn't know she worked for rihanna
and that makes me think that this is
even more untrue
i just feel like
they apparently have been hooking up for
a very long time but she's been working
for fenty for also a very long time like
right
literally how dumb are you and like when
did he have time to impregnate rihanna
and then go hook up with the person
that's like literally creating her shoes
and putting shoes on her feet and
posting her on instagram i don't know i
don't want to believe it i don't want to
believe it i don't really do it either
i love them together
and when this was just being reported as
facts i was like damn like
all these powerful women like rihanna
beyonce um chloe kardashian i was like
no none of the like the most powerful
successful rich beautiful stunning smart
women in the world even they are getting
like [ __ ] around with [ __ ] boys and
i'm like what the [ __ ] that was my first
thought it's so [ __ ] up and it's like
you have a baby on the way like why is
it always when the girl is pregnant oh
right like the season of real housewives
of new jersey jennifer aiden and bill he
cheated on her when she was like nine
months pregnant with their fifth kid
yeah i can't get involved i don't know
why men are just like so disgusting and
i'm not saying that this is true right
because i don't think that it is i don't
think that it is either but i feel like
it might also the only reason i think
someone has to address it is because of
the relationship potentially with amina
and fenty and like all of them
but at the same time like it might be so
stupid that they might not even address
it i don't know
yeah i mean i guess we'll know if this
is true if in the future amina muati
still works for fenty because it's
entirely possible that rihanna will take
asap rocky back and we could think like
oh this was never real but there's no
way that if it was real she would keep
that woman working for her so i guess
it's a billion dollar it's like a
something like a crazy like deal too
like the minimum the fenty deal yeah
that's what i read it's like a millions
of dollars and it was like lost million
of dollar deal i can't speak english but
we'll see that is such just like an
interesting piece of fashion news that i
didn't know yeah it's like sometimes
when you pretend to be a fashion girly
like you get the inside scoop as i stare
at my fake amina zara knockoffs and
straight up i mean her shoes are really
expensive and they're like super trendy
i think literally just go to zara i
literally got hot pink and they look
exactly this i think they're stunning
but i don't know if i would ever buy a
pair yeah no i don't have that morgan
stewart money yeah and i also like don't
i'm a big fan of investing like jackie
obviously has had her influence on me
but when it comes to certain things like
shoes that literally touch the ground in
new york i'm not like crazy about
spending money on shoes i'm a bad girly
for a second i was like what shoes don't
touch the ground and then i realized
that was the point the point like like
right you're walking around new york
there's feces there's rats there's
literal like diseases everywhere and i
just spent a thousand dollars on a pair
of shoes no thanks oh yeah no like
that's i mean in la i didn't have to
worry about that now in chicago i'm like
oh well you know i just need to not care
about these shoes anymore just crashed
i'm an amazon girl now right and you
know traveling around this great country
on
tour
i think the only pair of the only city i
would buy
shoes really expensive shoes in it's
like if i lived in dc because it was
extremely clean
interesting nation's capital
tell me about it so i'm just going to go
ahead and decide in my brain that this
is not true
100 like why would i why would i believe
this why would i believe this far some
thirst monster like it wasn't an actual
report like someone on social media
saying something doesn't make it fact
they described they described him as the
messiest fashion right so i think we all
need to remember that sometimes like
just because someone said on the
internet does not make it true
a men's sister
um okay including when i say something
about myself oh that's true right you're
your own you're your biggest enemy
hundred and birth
um moving on to a little royal news we
have some positive news finally coming
out harry and megan have finally
reunited with the queen
ever since the prince charles family
feud
so harry and megan have finally visited
queen elizabeth ii together for the
first time in more than two years the
duke and duchess of sussex i thought we
weren't supposed to call them that
anymore yes what i'm pretty sure
whatever they were reunited with the
monarch just days before her 96th
birthday they made a pit stop in the uk
while on their way over to the hague for
the invictus games i have no idea what
that is
and the 95 year old queen met with them
at her home windsor castle alongside
harry's father prince charles the couple
flew to london heathrow's airport from
their home in california and they left
their two kids whom the queen has still
never met in person at home
so i was researching stories today and
it's so funny how like you'll get
different
like perspectives because like explain
this to me so i saw this story on page
six and that's the one i just read from
and then when i was going to the daily
mail looking for other stories they had
like a royal expert saying that megan
and harry are exploiting their
relationship with the queen for their
netflix show
wait are they doing a reality show i
don't know what they're doing they have
all these weird projects like they
announced this big project with spotify
this big project with netflix disney
plus and then we like never got any
content from them so i'm not really like
100 sure what they do for a living you
know what i think they should do though
because i watched the kardashians hulu
last night
and let me tell you this is the best
thing that they ever decided to do and
i'm gonna i'm gonna tell you why though
because i listened to the podcast
yesterday to see if you said this it is
because there's no commercials and
there's no coming up like that's it is
just like you know how like before like
a commercial break on bravo they like
basically yeah they basically show you
everything yeah and so i'm watching this
and i'm like why is this so good like
obviously it's the breaking of the
fourth wall like the way they're
shooting it like the higher level
production everything like that but i
feel like if we got megan and hairy
version of that
that could be really sick because the
way they executed it oh my god the
execution of production is just amazing
no you're right and like when you think
about that e-show between the
commercials the coming up previously on
next week and then all the filler like
you know mj and scott doing a prank on
chris if if the whole episode is an hour
i would say the substantial content is
about three or four minutes don't you
feel like you
also like even though we obviously know
everything about the kardashians already
when you watch like the coming up on
this season i felt like there was so
much stuff that i like needed to know
and very long trailer like yeah i was
just like wait i want to get the details
like i'm 100 gonna keep watching it i
was absolutely shocked at how good it
was
i thought it was incredible it made them
even more likeable than they already are
which is like insane and i feel like
maybe
harry and megan need to do something
like that because like right now like
i'm sorry i don't give a [ __ ] about them
i know i did like the oprah interview
but that was a while ago right no i
think like when they first left there
was all this intrigue and now it's
definitely fizzled and they're just like
you know regular rich
socialites in america like um and they
haven't you're right but i don't know if
that's something they're doing
intentionally like they really did want
this normal life so maybe they don't
need
a tv show but i don't know i can never
tell if they're like so low-key or so
thirsty like i just can't decide it has
to be a mix because like also you like
grow up in a certain way and like your
your level of what you think is normal
is like what we think is thirsty just
because right you were like raised that
way but i feel like they're always going
to be close with the queen i mean
especially she's so old like i know it's
his grandma he's always had a soft spot
she's always had a soft spot it's just a
matter of like i mean god forbid the day
the queen leaves us
what's going to happen in the family
then that's going to be scary times it's
going to be scary because then the man
in charge is prince charles who's like a
[ __ ] i mean i only know i only refer to
prince charles and my brain is like what
i saw in the crowd the crown right yeah
like and i i don't i do not like you i
don't like you one bit he's not like you
know in order to lead a family like you
have to be extremely wise extremely um
patient and mature and selfless and just
especially any family but especially a
family like the royal family and charles
is the next one to be that and he is not
any of those qualities
i mean he's just like honestly like
this useless i'm sorry
the scum of the earth yeah i agree yeah
like i mean i don't like mean it like
passionately but like i just feel like
it's like a good you know it describes
him very well no he's a bad guy like
he's a bad guy yeah
i don't like him i'm happy that they're
reuniting i'm just like so i never know
what to believe with the royal stuff
because it's all just like reported so
differently depending on the outlet
yeah and it's like who's the royal
expert like why are you right
i'm a vile expert i watch the crown yeah
i'm a royal expert i have instagram like
i i i don't understand like is it coming
from the inside is it coming from the
outside i don't know i have no idea but
i do um
crave
an inside look at harry and megan's
house like that definitely because
they're the closest thing now that we
have to royalty in america except for
the kardashians
and the and the pelts beckham's um but
they really are i don't i do not stand
oh yeah i i'm a hundred percent not on
board with i know i know how do you not
think that they're like
not so all over each other
all the time nicola and
yeah it's like oh my god i love you baby
let me get 7 500 tattoos of like your
handwriting on my body and like tell
everyone how much i love you every
single day on social media like get a
life bro the thing is i'm new here like
i've never followed either of them on
social media i've been following nicola
for a week i still don't follow brooklyn
like i'm very new here so i don't see
what you see i'm still fresh i'm naive i
mean like listen like i follow nicola
too because like i want to see what
she's wearing of course and i think she
looked stunning but like there's just i
i honestly didn't think that they were
going to get married
just because they're so young i just
like thought like it was going to be
like a long engagement with like a
really big pretty ring and then
something would happen like hollywood
right hollywood yeah like but they're
married now and i guess they are
kind of i guess they're our royal family
too and he's also british oh by the way
we were talking about you on the toast
literally three days ago when oh yeah
well we said you would know because we
did she date greg sulkin no okay so she
didn't date greg salkin
this is what happened she met she was in
the movie transformers
and she that movie was produced by my
ex-boyfriend's dad and when he went to
go visit set and he saw her and said oh
my god that's the most beautiful girl in
the world keep in mind he still thought
that our entire relationship by the way
she is pretty stunning yeah no i know
but like imagine like him still thinking
she's the most beautiful girl in the
world
she's sleeping next to him yeah and it's
like sometimes like your personality
like has to make up for like what you
lack in other departments anyway
so cameron and nicola dated but i'm
pretty sure that i and don't quote me on
this and michelle i'm sorry if this is
wrong i think maybe greg and nicola
canoodles but the real relationship was
cameron aka my ex-boyfriend aka your
husband's friend [ __ ] you ben i'm just
kidding that's like literally
like everyone take a like step back take
a joke um and then she broke his heart
and
um
she was spotted she was spotted leaving
craigs with justin bieber while her and
cameron were together and cameron saw it
on just jared
the t me and jackie knew you would have
the day thank you for sharing that with
the toast i mean i just feel like it's
pertinent information and i'm far away
from this and i don't live in l.a
anymore right right
you hear things man oh my god that is so
fascinating yeah i don't know how we
went from the queen to that major shout
out to greg salkin i love him he's like
literally the best like he's so nice i
remember calling him like hysterically
crying after the breakup being like make
everyone leave me alone he's like lauren
take a breath
lorraine take a breath oh my god you are
out of control um but all i was trying
to say was that like i wouldn't mind an
mtv crib style
home tour for harry and megan
i want to see their chicken coop right
like there's just so much there even
though the chicken coop looked like kind
of gross
okay well
sorry like i want to be a farm girly
like i thought it was literally i
i love a bougie chicken coop like are
you kidding me me too they were just
like standing there with oprah and i was
like claudia you wouldn't want a chicken
coop don't lie no i'm like oprah is like
a queen like get her out of this farm
she deserves better
okay moving on to our next story which
is brought to you by starbucks by energy
energy drink the new starbucks by energy
drink with caffeine naturally found in
coffee fruit it's energy that's good
it's a beverage that's crafted from
caffeine naturally found in coffee fruit
as well as the antioxidant vitamin c
includes three delicious fruity flavors
mango guava raspberry lime and pineapple
passion fruit each 12 ounce 90 calorie
can contains 160 milligrams of caffeine
so personally you guys know i'm like not
really a coffee girl but i happen to
think that the mango guava all the
flavors are really good but the mango
guava is my favorite and i've been like
struggling to find some sort of caffeine
supplement because i don't drink coffee
and i think the starbucks bioenergy
drink is everything of the sort it's
only 90 calories you can and it's super
refreshing super energizing and just
delicious and i'm not like other girls
when i drink it so the starbucks bia
energy drink is available online at
grocery stores convenience stores and
gas stations nationwide again each 12
ounce can has 90 calories and 160
milligrams of caffeine it is a
refreshing flu
fruit flavored boost of feel good energy
in a way that only starbucks can deliver
all right next story are you in outer
banks girly lauren oh such a big outer
banks girly okay so chase stokes is like
yelling at his fans on social media and
like this morning i saw it this morning
too and like i get it because i think
fandoms
yeah like fandoms can be so toxic
especially ones that have like really
young fans um but i thought he was being
like a major drama queen so
he basically posted you know i'm not
even gonna read for me news i'll tell
you exactly from his story he posted on
his story like a selfie of him and a
woman the woman was his sister
it said she surprised me love you at
riley walk
then he posted another you know black
screen white text the fact that i can't
post a picture with my baby sister
without death threats is [ __ ] absurd
get a grip
family always comes first and at the end
of the day if you don't know my sister
and have the audacity to send me
horrific messages then just go ahead and
click on follow i will forever be a
person who always puts family first with
that being said and with that dumb [ __ ]
i'm out see you when i see you chase
so i definitely think like outer banks
is really toxic like i've seen like a
lot of stuff
from like social media posts like
attacking all the cast i definitely is
annoying
but um this like attacking all of the
casts yeah like just the girl like
there's just like a lot of toxicity
within the fandom panda okay see i did
not know this because that's gen z is
the fan right and this is like not the
first time he's been like you know [ __ ]
off yeah
so i just don't know if this is like a
hill worth dying on
well see i think i was confused because
didn't you see a few weeks ago where it
kind of seemed like him and madeleine
got back together it was confusing and
then
ross butler and zach b it was very
confusing yeah but then so like after
ross butler and after zac bia there was
a moment where i was like i think
they're back together yeah and i wasn't
sure
and then that kind of fizzled out and
when i saw this i'm not even like a huge
like super super fan but i just i i
didn't even click on the tag that he
tagged because i just like for some
reason automatically assumed it was a
sister yeah and then i got to that slide
and i was like
okay so
calm down i yeah like i feel like like
step one is like take a step back like
maybe like look inward for a moment in
time and it's just yeah
you're not you think that people are
that smart that they're gonna like click
on it and realize it's your sister and
then like not send you a stupid message
like you've been doing this for a while
now you know i could just never be one
of those people who's like unfollow me
like no please don't follow me like you
don't literally keep sending me depth
like you literally keep sending me death
threats i need more followers i need
help
likes my promo code and then kill me
like
100
i just think that like he's so hot but
he's clearly like so sensitive yeah and
i feel as though like i can help him
with that
[ __ ] i could see you guys being like
a cute couple even though like after he
broke up with madeline there were all
these videos of him like blacked out in
the back of like bars like being wasted
maybe and it was really through a dark
time it was like really unattractive
yeah i mean like can't relate to that
like we were
we are always a picture of elegance
yes we were at the club last weekend
with our sipping tea
sipping tea like the queen
yeah no i just feel like he doesn't like
understand fame completely because all
those kids really got like kind of
plucked from a slight obscurity yeah
like they were all like i've you know
i've done my homework and stuff but i
just feel like he just kind of needs to
i just think maybe have some like
healthy boundaries with social media
because like his star needs to keep
rising right she needs to like stop
being such a drama queen and yelling at
your fans like every other week is not
the way to just be like it's my sister
or freaks yeah like don't go on like a
long paragraph as if it's like this like
family first family over everything yeah
thank you for sure but like thank you
for bringing that up yes
i don't really understand like family i
mean i'm family over everything is
literally like my core value but i don't
understand how it's applicable right
situation like
that's what i'm saying what what like
what is the cut like no i've literally
don't get it yeah like when it
when the hate involves my sister then
it's family over everything perhaps okay
perhaps
but also
calm down yeah no this was like a gross
overreaction
yeah just like literally you could have
done like two lines like even post like
a funny picture with your sister being
like oh my god you guys like calm down
my sister like bye
yeah but instead he's not
right no when you when you whip out the
black screen white text like you're in
trouble
yeah you're like dear diary
um so the next story is something we
actually uh it's like an update to a
story we never reported it on um last
week hillary baldwin is pregnant again
oh yeah
um and normally yeah you're scraping the
bottom of the barrel today well normally
well it is a friday which means like
there's no stories and normally like i
don't care to talk about this fraudulent
american queen um but alec baldwin is
finally responding to people asking him
why he's having so many children because
i think they're on their seventh or
their eighth and it's like
i'm all for big families like i said
family over everything
but um it's a lot it's just a lot of
children and no matter how much money
you have like it's still a lot
so i wanted to get down to the bottom of
it alec baldwin finally clarified why he
and his wife hilaria sorry hillary
keep on popping out kids and it's
because they love it the 30 rock alum
posted a video to instagram thursday of
his daughter maria luisa i'm at them
like naming their kids like latin
inspired names
the fraud knows no bounds
maria lucia
um so he wrote people ask why this is
why
being a parent is the ultimate journey
so they already are are
so they're on their seventh kid seventh
pregnancy seventh kid yeah so if it's
the ultimate journey what's the
destination 100
100 like what are we shooting for
like 10 i don't know and it's just
the hate i have in my heart for these
two
is really balanced
it's bad
it's bad but may i ask though i don't
want to aid shame or mama shane jackie
or anything like but how old is she like
like she's still like that fertile like
she's popping them out no i mean i only
say this because i get nervous me too of
course that's all like i mean i wish i
could
oh my god she's so young no i know that
she is definitely like the picture of
fertility health it's like not holy [ __ ]
normal to like get pregnant that
frequently and what appears to be very
easily
it's just a lot of kids it seems
oh and by the way it doesn't matter how
much you have that's not even to mention
the kids alec baldwin has from previous
marriages ireland oh so maybe he is at
10 now okay let's see i don't know any
other eight
i like bond when kids i don't know the
other kids besides ireland because she's
like the most famous imagine how much
money you have to make to support seven
to ten children
right that
is just i i like i wouldn't know unless
i was kylie jenner right now and like of
course alec baldwin wants the best for
his kids private schools yeah you know
tutors it's literally a million dollars
a year per kid i mean hilaria definitely
wants the best for her children she
oh my god
uh did you watch bad vegan on netflix do
you know that i started it um and i
didn't really understand the hype but i
thought the alec baldwin of it all was
incredibly bizarre very interesting and
bizarre and the way she was talking
about it when she set them up yeah and
she was like i could have ended up with
him but i set him up with hilaria anyway
and i'm just like wow you gave her a
platform bad vegan wasn't overhyped it
was really good like i did end up
falling asleep but i think it i was like
a little it was so good i ended up
falling asleep you know like i don't
like sometimes it's just like something
so good it just like puts you to bed
like yeah
so relaxing
nothing like fraud is so relaxing
[Music]
no it was really good and like alec
baldwin like the fact that they were
screenshotting his tweets too and it was
like oh my god i love pure food and wine
and like i go there to see this woman
like oh my god it's so embarrassing and
you know freak me and jackie are always
talking about that how like these random
documentaries
always have like a weird celebrity
element to them yeah like the wework
documentary gweneth paltrow was in there
because she was like cousins with the
girls have you watched wait did you you
watched the hulu thing but have you
started the apple tv thing no i have not
yet it's so good i'm like loving anne
hathaway these days she is so good in it
he is so good in it i literally was
shocked because
i didn't i thought it was just gonna be
okay or just look good but i was like
wow this is actually amazing i heard you
talk about the dropping guy jared leto
okay who i'm not like a huge fan of in
general because he's like a method actor
and kind of like a little freaky um he
just like gives me like like the highest
of the high la vibes where i'm right
like spooky yeah um but she oh my god is
amazing in it oh wow
it it just like it really feels like wow
these two people were freaks like i
forgot how big of freaks they were like
the biggest loser energy on the planet
uh like
adam newman
rebecca paltrow rebecca
yeah losers poor gweneth
so embarrassing
i feel like there is there just needs to
be a club of like alec baldwin
adam newman ashton kutcher was in the um
the
wework documentary as well he did this
like interview it was so embarrassing
well because he believed in adam newman
right time
i have like a really soft spot for adam
coach or adam
right now because i have you watched uh
what happens in vegas lately with ashton
kutcher and cameron diaz i haven't seen
it in years but i know it okay so like
if you want to give it a re-watch like
maybe if when you're like a little like
hungover in the morning like oof like i
just i love him he's so hot but i
thought you were gonna say that he's a
soft spot in your heart because him and
his wife who's ukrainian are doing like
amazing work for ukraine oh i mean
obviously that too but like i'm not
that's what i don't know what we're
gonna say no no i'm not like other girls
i'm not gonna give you the obvious
answers right i'm gonna take you down
memory lane baby
backing up so it is time for our fifth
and final story lauren of course so
i don't want to know us by anyone it is
but i want to know if you might want to
sing the song
i'd rather [ __ ] die okay i'll say
it's the
put yourself on mute practice no
yeah yeah you have to do it
this is what we do at the morning shows
we bring people out of their shells
oh my god
lauren's gorgeous performance of the
final story is brought to you by blue
land did you know that an estimated 5
billion plastic hand soap and cleaning
bottles are thrown away each year and if
that's not bad enough each bottle can be
made of more than 90 water it's a
lose-lose situation for the planet and
it's 2022 we have to stop wasting water
and throwing out more plastic and get
blue land's revolutionary refill
cleaning system instead so their idea at
blue land is very simple
buy the bottle once refill it forever
there's no more plastic waste the only
thing you need is to discard is your
outdated idea that eco-friendly products
are more expensive just fill blue lands
beautiful instagramable bottles with
warm water pop in one of the hand soap
or the spray cleaner tablets and within
minutes you'll have a powerful cleaning
product in the most incredible sense
like iris agave purine lemon lavender
eucalyptus their stunning high quality
forever bottles start at just ten
dollars when you buy the kit and they
are meant to be reused forever with
money saving refill tablets that start
at just two dollars so try blue land
today you'll love it and the planet will
thank you right now you can get 20 off
your first order when you go to
blueland.com
toast that's 20 off your first order of
any blue land products at blueland.com
toast i can attest to the scents being
gorgeous really effective cleaning
products and less wasteful so when you
live in a small apartment you don't have
a lot of space to like stock up on
cleaning products their tablets are
really small easy to store that's
blueland.com
toast
okay lauren how are you feeling
i mean it's just like um here's the
thing you know i lost my voice last week
and
i have nodes no
yeah that's very serious yeah
yeah it's like a serious condition so
i'm gonna let you take it but i'd love
to add
[Music]
[Music]
thank you so much for coming on the
morning toast
all right
terrible news for people who aren't me
peloton is increasing its subscription
fees starting june 1st so they announced
today that they are increasing the price
of the subscription fees in the us and
canada starting on june 1st how much the
cost of the company's all-access plan is
increasing from 39 to 44 is that a
monthly thing you pay
i believe so
and in canada it's going from forty nine
dollars to fifty five dollars so peloton
notes that this is the first time
they've increased their subscription
fees and the cost of the digital only
plan will remain at 12.99
the thing is
um didn't the stock go down or something
like are they they're always having
problems
but the thing is like i'm actually
surprised we're not seeing more like
prices go up because
with inflation like inherently our i
believe do not quote me on this i'm not
an economics girl but your dollar is
worth less like me and jackie were
saying like technically
yeah every couple years like our patreon
should be increased in value
of inflation yeah and while that is true
i think the same goes for like other
services
well i'm i saw uh like even
at like the nail salon and stuff like uh
in the new year not the new year i guess
just a few months ago whatever
everything went up just like a couple
dollars because it does like cover it
for them too but that's also a coveted
thing because nails yeah yeah like when
i when i but it went up even more when i
went back to my nail salon for the first
time post covered a gel manicure was
fifty dollars oh [ __ ] but that nail
salon has since gone out of business
which is so sad um
but like there's no winning because you
either have to charge insane prices but
no one's going to pay that but i don't
know if peloton's going out of business
necessarily i don't know i think to make
people pay 44 a month or whatever it is
um when they also bought a 3 000 bike is
insane
but
one
workout class
at like soul cycle or rumble boxing or
something is like 25 30
yeah but a walk on the elliptical is
free like i can't right but like you
have to get the elliptical from
somewhere that's either a gym membership
or an overpriced apartment complex right
right no i hear you that's why i walk
outside just right i have a gym here
right oxygen is free
oxygen is free but no i mean i think if
you're like a peloton girlie you just
like love peloton and maybe you can just
live with this that's the thing no it's
like a cult so they're yeah obviously i
don't think people are gonna be happy
like jackie loves her peloton and i'm
sure she's not thrilled that the price
is going up but i think that if you love
it so much and it's like a huge part of
your life like you're just gonna pay
it's the same way that like we hate that
netflix is raising their
costs for the subscription but none of
us are gonna cancel well that's yeah
exactly the choke hold they have us in
oh like you think i'm canceling my
netflix subscription my hulu
subscription has gone off gone up i
think 75 times in the past two years and
every time i'm like oh well darn that is
what it what am i gonna do like there's
this certain aspect where like i'm all
for
enacting change and
being on the forefront getting on the
front lines you're a change maker i'm a
change maker i'm a peace practicer
but there are so many things where i'm
just like
this is the world we live in and i'm
just going to like keep accept it yeah
like i i love accepting the things i
cannot change
and one of the things we cannot change
is netflix pelton hulu hbo max
increasing their subscription and you
know what in this day and age i think
it's something we're going to have to
get used to because that is literally i
think the definition of inflation right
well yeah but but the only thing that
i'm just going to expose myself for
bringing a [ __ ] more same i took econ
in college but that's right go to
college so good on you right but the
only thing i don't get is if
everything's increasing wouldn't that
mean it's like
if two dollars increases to four
and one increases to two isn't isn't it
like the same ratio though
oh i know it's we're not getting paid
more
right so our cost of living goes up
while what we're getting paid
technically is going down got it see
sometimes you just have to work it out
like walk through it someone is
screaming in their car right now i know
i'm gonna get an email like hi i'm a
financial analyst i would love to come
on the toast and explain inflation and
honestly i really feel like when it
comes to economics the less you know the
better because i need to sleep at night
and knowing that like
right like i just heard someone say like
if you're not investing your money right
now
you're losing money because of inflation
so the the value of let's say you have a
thousand dollars in savings the value of
that is going down because the value of
the dollar is going down so if you're
not investing it and like making money
and that gave me such bad anxiety so i
just want to know less yeah no i i think
like a important thing to note is that
like
i'm not saying ignorance is bliss
because like i'm rolling in cash i'm
saying ignorance is bliss is because if
i think about it my anxiety is so
crippling i can't do anything so
exactly what you're saying i just want
to like be clear that i'm not i don't
have this financial situation under
control um
at all like literally majority of things
on my body are from amazon right so
which is fine
jeff bezos is i'm sure doing fine daddy
but you know i actually was considering
getting not getting a peloton there's
pelton in my building
and all it takes um for me being single
is really one guy being like you should
try a peloton and i'm like oh my god
like let me try it cuz like let me just
purchase one right now let me just
purchase one because then like maybe
you'll like me so i have been thinking
about it
it's just so that i can like tell the
guy that i was like oh like i was on the
palatine oh sorry i couldn't answer the
text that was pelotonic it was so crazy
as on the peloton do you know what i'm
doing next weekend by the way before um
we go because i just want people to
understand that they should really take
dating advice from me yeah um
i'm going to miami with a hinge boy
yeah
oh my god straight
for it
okay so like i'm not like other girls
and like i don't want to like look like
that girl that is using someone for
something yeah so i'm gonna obviously
like make him pay for everything once
we're there in a sense of like yeah like
pay for my drinks like pay for my food
have you been out with this man before
yeah we've been on like quite a few
dates
we're not exclusive though like we're
not exclusive like we're quote unquote
just having fun
and
um he was like i want to go somewhere
and i was like i want to go somewhere
and he's like let's go to miami i was
like okay because i am literally wild
and free flying together like you
meeting him there no we're flying
together
lauren that's crazy i know i'm out of
control i just want to inspire everyone
just be safe and like send me your
location
oh my god obviously i'll send you my
location like maybe i'll get on the
peloton before i go i mean i'm going to
miami
like
i just think about that
i think that with inflation now is the
time to get on the dating apps
get on the peloton i agree and get
everything in order because we don't
know what's going to happen next it's
all interesting
i wouldn't be going on dates and going
to miami if it wasn't for [ __ ]
conversation yeah like making sense that
makes total sense i really do i'm sorry
i also don't apologize i also want to
apologize for um going on so many
tangents this whole podcast
but it's hard when it's like you're my
actual friend i forget that we're
recording a show me too
um but with that i will bid everyone ado
i hope everyone has an amazing weekend
for all of our jewish listeners
happy passover hope everyone has a great
couple of days with their family and
happy easter right it's sunday
happy easter to all of our easter
girlies he has risen mazel tov
big big weekend big weekend huge huge
huge um so i love you guys thank you so
much for listening to the morning show
someone in a morning show lauren you are
a queen everyone make sure to listen to
lauren's podcast mood with lauren
elizabeth oh also i wanted to ask you
you've been having like fire [ __ ]
a-list guests on your podcast and i want
to know how karama was
oh my god he was amazing he literally
gave like the best advice especially um
i was about to you know want to take
tacos in your head i was like the best
advice for women in business no the best
advice for dating
it feels like no one wants to hook up
with me anymore it's just like get your
[ __ ] ass up and hook up with me um so
he gave incredible incredible dating
advice he is so wise he has a metaphor
for absolutely everything that we had
josh peck on who was also on the toast
and
he also just gave like such great advice
for like dark times honestly we've had
some really really really good guests
that are just so
inspiring that
literally make me just so glad like just
so grateful that i get to talk to them
so it's definitely a different version
of me over on that podcast for sure
you're a little unhinged today which i
like well there's a different girl for
different things i think i can do your
outro by the way
okay i'll let you do it but you're
unhinged on hinge
okay do the actually go for lauren
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast this is the millennial
morning show where we go live every
monday through fire [ __ ] you're [ __ ]
up you're [ __ ] up okay fine go thank
you so much for listening to the morning
toast the millennial morning show where
we deliver the fast five stories that
you need to know every monday through
friday on youtube so if you're watching
this on youtube please feel free to
subscribe give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast and
we're podcasts we found so spotify
itunes district public video i already
cast box all the places would be listed
in the podcast finance more joseph if
you've ever beautiful stunning and smart
we are lauren i love you toasters i love
you have a great weekend happy holidays
everyone and we'll see you on monday